what's up everybody welcome back first
snack here in Puerto Rico the last ten
coyote events a gym and now Rend is in
for Romanova indeed glad to be here glad
to be in Puerto Rico first time at first
attack and the Dragon Ball fighters
action has always been good so it's
looking like we're gonna get some more
matches where I trying to narrow it down
to the top 32 so I see that you missed
the last match the a yard match so what
happened I was having a romantic walk
with Logan saw him on the beach Porto
Rico's big-booty Jackson defeated
Alucard and wine and make it in the top
30 to Wilson big boo Jackson was got
playing out yeah so I saw the match I
was just unaware of the name yeah I
figured you'd enjoy the name you know
it's funny as he's been following me all
day I was commentating over there and he
was on the stage the whole time so he
sit down here and like he shows up I was
like I know big booty Jackson and the
way Romanova looked at me I was like I
look you understand I got some
explaining to do but come on bro like I
know who I'm familiar there's not a lot
of cats out here from Puerto Rico
including the two on the stage here we
got a honey badger versus Tom Tom while
representing wait up I like the way he
put that ice it's plate yeah that's
pretty good
cool they bring to the table we got the
dashes and the Z changes being altered
you know honey badger and yourself both
have these long
hairdos then you got going on does it
hang up in the humidity oh man look this
bad yeah it's about a foot I think so
yeah I imagined that it was pretty rough
and humidity in general yeah so that's
why time I join up I see cook yeah head
walking around the beautiful corner
region country but I mean the humidity
is definitely something that's not good
you gotta be wary of yeah it's
definitely rough especially for people
who are not used to the humidity I feel
like it's very brutal oh yeah we call
from dry heat yeah drying it's you know
you can manage it this is very different
we're all spaced I'm swimming while I
walk yeah we're going to space Android
16 the way you set the controller down
makes me feel like this is a bunch a oh
yeah I'm not sure he's also inquiring
about something to the side they're also
both playing Bartok 21 Goku and Vegeta
whoa I don't know what's going on here
Oh spicy start to this one this is pull
see 18 winners and as all he's got a
bandana up what just like Bardo oh you
know he's got to do it wild Bardock no
see
that's what I was thinking also I'm
upset that he cut off the intro while he
did it that's cold what oh man Oh dual
shock issue my man is a brought the red
bandana Santana just put match bar dog
I'm sure he's a Bartok player oh now
he's like look I need to go get another
pad oh my left thumb sticks not working
remember to get a camel pad so they
can't see your mix-ups that's the
craziest thing sage has ever said hey
The Last of Us on this console
the first one second what's not out yeah
I think that's correct I never played
the first one I think I just belongs
copy I believe you I don't know why but
I get the inclination that that's
correct from back in the day with Justin
used to live in the Marina del Rey
beautiful Southern California it's been
a minute now though so it looks like
we're still hammering out these issues
with the DualShock seems to have an
inner unresponsive analog analog type
that's the thing is like I was gonna say
do you plan on analog is that an issue I
mean I've heard of people doing
I think super noon desert a despicable
super goon yeah I think he is one of the
many who used yield and analog and being
the sparking to his touchpad that's the
worst thing I've ever heard control it
and we're like why he's like because I
just want to mash it yeah like it
doesn't make any second you imagine if
you're a peddler at home imagine mapping
sparking to your touchpad literally home
you just gotta use his forehead to hit
it if you lost the spark to spark up
boom just like hit it with your he's
like a Power Ranger you know he's gonna
call it out just like crashes his pose
is just smacking his head into the
touchpad dude that's the strangest thing
I've ever heard why would you map your
entire touchpad to Spartan what happens
when you go to hit the touchpad you hit
the PlayStation button yeah you know
it's like in the vicinity man well
apparently I've never heard him complain
about it so he's actually execution when
it comes to the sparking touchpad it's
impeccable yeah apparently that's as
good as his Bartok
did you see that you talked about
playing kickball card which I believe he
has done I mean not for extended period
of time I think yeah I think of a nice
thing to saying so that has a reply on
the bench or at least put him in a
position that's high I voted his bar
lock off the island like I straight told
him that his Baraka strategies like no
bro watch this his bartosh first I'm
like super native New York paradox no
good to reveal the church the I see well
so now the headband has to come back
yeah I thought he was gonna have some
bar talk shirt on underneath with the
initial
there has been so much build-up to this
match did you miss earlier when
big-booty Jackson came onstage his
opponent pulled out a recorder J and
started playing like playing and big
dude it goes high this is like the only
tournament I feel like any of these
events I can tell you this and it would
be the truth I need you guys to keep it
on this street oh come on time it with
the bar dog he's gotta go kenchi mode
and just like cover his eyes I was gonna
request from production to keep it on
this screen while the intros played so
he could see the simultaneous bandanna
but looks like he's not gonna well by
the time he finishes we need a powerup
no but he tied it at the exact same time
I'm impressed by that sounds really good
yeah it's like you heard the audio cue
who is hands are hurt and I know that
feeling what they you won't have to feel
that get about it alright so we started
off here mirror bad except for the back
end where we got it Super Saiyan Goku
vs. blue Goku oh yeah let me add Vegeta
yeah yeah take the the mix of nothing
yeah it work bro wait oh yeah see I
didn't see for a second that he's I
couldn't his headphones ah he's probably
playing about these dude oh my god he
turned to him and after he got snapped
he said hey hold on I got to put the
headphones on he put the headphones on
the middle of the match and then they
kept playing I wanna smack the
controller you gotta be kidding me
that's why they thought he was like a
lip on the headphones real quick
nah bro I go to doll gala school
tournament play you give me an
opportunity I'll pay you to kill combo I
cannot believe that just happened
well honey badger if they take down the
first character barred off his death row
we got the Jester and verse 21
[Music]
to stop the instant transmission in the
air to just not high enough off the
ground all right should be the drop goes
for the air jump 8 into 6 out oh I don't
feel that we were jumping put up the
blocks that I bring to the ground we got
six atlases keeping it nice and simple
we had all the bar in the world to get
the
yeah javelin for the finish you can hear
the beautiful audio pumping now that
he's got the headset on rebellions here
to start it off wait up top I'm not
expecting any got all computer in the
world this is going to get the place
all right spark up does click the assist
as well the five LS unfortunate yeah all
right yes same way we started yeah
sometimes you double side switch with
the light light and it's not on accident
yeah it's totally on purpose
that's right level three he's got dragon
harsh on accident the apples definitely
looking for the level 3 dragon war
towards the corner wait that's Margot
I'm get scooped up
a smartphone honey badger over to age
yeah I'll go after Sparky's running out
to the ground
yes Larry three so I'm not gonna kill
but gonna put up a one hit away from
death
yeah I mean not gonna regain any life
either since it's full air - over mints
on the cross left jump edge of town oh
the command grab again buddy challenging
this part successfully with the stand
light to give this matter start down
here it's always fast the kill 21:21
action yeah yeah
now he's talking to him he's like hey
man my analog it's turtle time
turns out go back to the character
select a real quick I don't know what he
asked about maybe different stage
different colors different colors you
gotta get the function where right yeah
maybe he took his color
eternity strikes that is something
strong to be bear if you know that there
are team is like all blue just take the
blue color taking it to the Cell Games
arena that was like picking like when
you play like Dante Virgil yeah
everybody had to match their Dante for
game right so you had to be real quick
yeah if you messed up my Dante Virgil
I'm the unforgivable what color did you
play white bread a red red red Virgil
red dots
I played the fault dogs and the rippers
yeah that makes I yes I honestly didn't
like the blue Dante color so I didn't
like playing blue Dante default I think
those seems like best in black or white
oh yeah star always Vegeta
so if we go back on the bench injured
reserve see the jitta can aid him in the
neutral oh it's quit blow and then no
confirmed maybe try to do jump and he
discussed exam
they're that forward Noah says drive in
a rush yeah honey battle taking
advantage of that frantic pace that he
really set up at the beginning of this
around to sneak it better dragon rush
the best parts are doing you just got
your opponent up against the ropes
they're still concern about blocking
they get caught I gotta level 3 or
scuffle Samer while try to take the back
- grill is bad then hold flight back -
I'm surprised on the Vegeta's cuz
there's the reflec put the second into
the light condom yeah the good news in
the corner but looking sunny them
anywhere right so yes relied on the
Harlow couple and use the line up a 2h
right there honey badger can extend with
the Goku as well Auto combo smash
upwards yeah it's the kill
one javelin needs to be the honey badger
lookin great just like that continues as
momentum from the first game yeah super
- Jin gets eaten up by the end of the
Vegeta so
yeah after a super dad does go through a
hole straight up Joe le look getcha go
behind the back yeah it started I was a
medium but it's alright it's alright
knocked out it's been jump out stand out
dumbbell stand out that's baby more
bilingual in PR yeah the lord of the
light bus
we just hit square then we need one yes
man I like that directly change in the
bar dog it's a little character but the
stronger point there's our our readers
drop the combo in the end yeah
mrs. on the 21 and since pickets they
hit after will see yeah allocate its
meter at the end of it I feel like you
want hi he's gonna run this point Vegeta
yeah I think level 3 would have been
worth it there yeah hit away from dying
yet some bars all reset with an auto
combo it's all part to play it like this
he had both of up and then he didn't and
then he did you just got the auto couple
at the end holds the punish killed honey
badger all drops it if he is gift having
an opportunity here did he make the
legendary come back no the bag to give
everything he walks right now say Jim if
he makes this comeback let's go all he
tried for the cheeky air reset scooped
up I couldn't even think about what I
was gonna do orange bugs or air-launched
they've got the mater pair going on I
see you that's cool good way does he
take the headband off is the question
now every man she's gonna put the
headband off put the jacket back on put
the controller back in its case he
simply looks at the screens like why
this third blue cameras go off me we
want to see what you do with that
headband dawg that's all that's a good
question I mean now that it's not on him
does he just like rip it off he's like I
get rid of this headband so they don't
know it's me yeah
gotta get rid of it I switch to t go on
bro the other Lord of Light yeah he is
man we've had some bad ones today
oh yeah the bad teen gohan swingin' dude
the very first thing that happened when
I sat down was like big booty Jackson
recorder
he was life sign of life I understand no
dude it was all right back to back to
back you have to understand dragon ball
big booty Jackson matches did you
compensate to at the very least two or
three two cuts the reporter and Alec are
yeah another earlier two or three oh man
it's been a lot today it's it's been a
lot I've been on for a while that's true
yeah you've been putting in the work
here at first attack yeah continue my
ieg event hey look at that
that's ray-ray it is indeed ray-ray he's
not wearing a white t-shirt he's not
that's a little strange
slight v-neck I like the slight I feel
like he's always had the slight v-neck
he's a big fan that's showing the
hamburger meat Steve always says it yeah
boys he's been a big fan of the
hamburger feet dangling it kid just say
that familiar he's talking about the
chest hair that's popping out at the top
of the shirt yes in case anyone doesn't
know what the reference of hamburger be
this funny new we got ray ray of course
an incredibly successful versus game
player you know his history at marvel 3
it was a very good at marvel infinite as
well taking his talents to Dragonball
fighters see how he does here he's
always been super good with the movement
in this game ride which is no surprise
if you know this history is a marvel so
we'll see how he had translates here and
a 10k each event ranking some points
qualify for that finals in France I
forgot he plays a masu I knew I knew you
play Kid Buu yet but I didn't remember
what his point character was I feel like
I saw him playing on a home stream like
a month or two ago yeah he's still
usually at the Dragon Ball sessions that
happened in New York so it's not like he
hasn't been playing yeah how you MPR
from starting it off with he worked here
and I think some say folk with a packet
forest try nante lung yeah a little bit
too far doesn't catch up with the to em
yeah the orbs admin of comlink it's like
cool it's insane to I like that ask the
recommend to the agents to fall the best
manslaughter down follow up on I even
call I got a system you try to be
another pledge yeah something Shannon
sister was gonna come and that should do
it for cooler cannot connect this device
using a USB cable or register it again
gets the job done as he usually do
wow it's not enough time even after the
way how pretty good
Genesis thumbs ahead son
oh I like that super dodge doesn't even
go with an air - afterwards where I just
land and hit some of the empty low yeah
and then it's 2l keeps it up at the key
blast
level three hopeful City fair game
sparking bait or not suppression Compal
off the light / into the orbs love the
testimony early keep it nice and simple
[Music]
then just dominating the neutral was the
BA so at this point hasn't taken a
scratch of damage a you see ray ray is a
long time player of game for the sits
he's very conservative with a long walk
the talent appoints where he's sure
that's gonna be optimal for flag he
doesn't get the punish actually
here - it doesn't get a combo [ __ ] to
assist available this is very good
all the MP lowered kids consistently
goes with an option isn't paying off
lover three screen man yeah as ten
assists for the follow-up mix-up here
with Kid Buu as well sparks up after the
ball missed the combo Cottam law didn't
complete it it's a monster this is air -
solar got pulled out of the corner of
the old classroom yeah that's definitely
the classic with kid we're right since
you're sparking and gives you the
ability to jump cancel your bugs around
almost you'll bring them out with the 1m
and then you just it's the Nair that's
right old remember cross the ball
you remember possible I do man how did
Kid Buu not win every tournament battle
crazy it was so good yeah what a
character across the ball the two or
three ends didn't scale like they do now
yeah
we didn't know when we know now yeah put
the fly also they look small so we can
block out and drop the counselor either
one thing yeah bat canceling the normal
there drop in Adana says so pretty yeah
that's good essentially problem 110 okay
jump age folks I'm still trying to
wiggle out yeah maybe ever looks like
gonna wake up for something I don't know
yeah who the slime Lotus are and I'll
get the combos as the boss Louis's as
well yeah I got his around start on sale
Oh kick through then all gets put below
by that too now and that's to do it for
hit moves hit by this medium John Bates
a couple of times yeah I got the counter
here
cool called blue summer a rate as always
yeah [ __ ] down I was Go Go hey what
happened
9 so I got all the meter in the world he
ran TN all point so he can unload a shot
if he wants to
yeah vol 1
in a purple city is gonna be a lot of
damage here so how does this flood the
smart based I'll be right here right
you know what's to be fair it was very
well-hidden it was good fair well I hate
to work but smarty man was obvious but
it wasn't you know what I mean like it
was an obvious parking bait but it was
very well hit it was like yeah when the
situation was being presented it's like
okay this marking baits gonna be here i
but when he touched it like that it
definitely looked like he was committing
to an option and so in the moment you
can get bids that's nothing to be
ashamed about sure yeah normally that's
why people try to smart kind of blocks
them yeah because they want to make sure
that they're blocking something and it's
not a baby so if you have a bait out of
blocks done then you're next level I was
gonna say like you saw an OPC right I
forgot who did I think was childish
vegeto I'd ran up 5l tang yeah but you
don't you block a 5ml and do spark but
he had the wrong tag come in and beat it
on so he lost our match I think - yeah
it's alright that's the only part I
remember I didn't tell me - that's the
part I remember - hey it looks like
somebody we've been talking a lot about
it on the stage super Nunes do you see
that big touchpad at the center of his
controller that's a sparking about anger
I'm seeing a more superdude shirt in my
life why does he have a shirt that just
says anger just say anger he went to
like a Korean website and pay 25 dollars
in shipping to have a shirt sent over to
the house that just says anger I mean to
be fair that is the mind of a kid boo
player that's what I'm saying though
right and super nude I mean I don't know
if he's the channel some anger or what I
feel like his biggest problem is like
his mental composure his mental strength
yeah right a lot of times his
self-confidence is what gets in the way
of him doing well so I think you know I
don't know if it's just throwing all the
emotion but anger to the wind or what
he's like a print animal yeah he's like
a sin incarnate or well I'm not sure
[Music]
all righty people were taking care of us
here from one that's why you heard the
moment of silence you know I'm just
letting on my entire life read I was not
placing an order for coffee
I see it had nothing to do with that
written I was just reflecting on my
inner self and reflecting that I
appreciate each and every one of you
viewers tuning into first attack here at
Puerto Rico
oh yeah guys are all sweet humans thanks
for checking out some Dragon Ball
fighters and look at that super dude put
in the kid boo all coy Bardock in the
secondary position that's a good look
good way to start but it's opponent on
the other side got B Gogeta
we'll see how experienced super noon is
with that I know he usually toys around
with the DLC characters when they come
out they've been a streamer he must them
yeah the only streamers who didn't try
go G are the people with broken hands
like me I tried that's too bad early hit
Spartan clover in trouble yeah no just
available book
pack that stomp the toys H mystic ball
combos off the key blind yeah just built
an assist back didn't combo but texting
it links after borrows its advantage
he's looking to go to the dark side of
the forest man that's prefer he ended up
hitting over the loan it's the fibers
combo as well yeah smart clothes we've
got a chance here
lotta damage we're gonna bring in the
help your good ol no took it to the end
and they hit start
what's up yeah it's mystic ball and
super noon big chillin you cannot let
him get an early stop her head into
sparking maths then
to age alright super news side switch
something were used to sing to him
unlike the rest of his play so far his
back
yeah blocks the sparking on the ground
catch the love super there right there
if you block this marking off the ground
it is your turn
yes they're blocking here where your
neck though yes those low jump ball set
up and they love the Wilkey blast easy
pcs got 5 meters
yeah the region is there by matter yeah
one one three mayo burn through yeah
this is Goku yes don't you ever dream
about the best for getting buried yeah
yeah takes a long time
no fear at all but I like that cancels
into the 2h as he makes a block the
first one
oh good good mix up and it's like a
great mix up one it's gonna kill exactly
that's like when you need it you don't
need it any other time so clean first
game from a super nanny yeah that's one
of those foods that just makes you
immediately attacked right so yes
wonderful kill ya sit nice challenged on
the run off same thing with like the hit
to blow overhead it's like a lot of
things like Asimov so you have the same
[Music]
apartment yeah thanks watch the jump
baits in the air nice Gatling to get the
2h just part of the string so we beat
the car canceled by the one and that's a
real rough way to get over the dog yeah
it didn't actually expect that he had
already called the assist and everything
but that's to go good awareness and it
just went from super duper to complete
that combo writers continue all the
pilot is what he's going to do yeah I
mean it's been all super noon so far we
got the New York Knicks part all they
have a good turn
nice I'm surprised that Ichigo quizzes
didn't mess it up
we have this cover in Lahti that's gonna
get a following mixes I thought that was
a plan but it seemed like it faded
nothing and then got the killing right
eventually found the reflect that I
guess was looking for either way yes sir
a saloon same position we saw life sign
get through on points less barking
hugely for super dude here
oh yeah that's gonna be negative use the
- OS anyway yeah
say say if I the efforts of banana
what we got here with the headstock shot
to H of the sparking spark up yeah
definitely this point and super nails
gonna run out sparking soon man kids
getting clipped by that one hands on the
stagger pressure and they kill it wonder
why I was trying to reflect or like you
he's just standing up all right elevator
oh yeah over Spartan clover that's he
have the black Air Force Ones on that's
what I want to know he tweeted the
picture he's got the angry t-shirt angry
anger anger yeah that's so funny such a
super new venture right away her he
takes his time getting up to the station
so I don't know if we're good see the
black Air Force Ones or not but I'll let
y'all know some other time
thank you for tuning in that's what ITV
/ Dragonball Fighters we are here super
new in advancing in winners hoping to
get that top 32 spot and top 32 is going
down tonight I believe it going the 30
to 60 yeah I think that's the night so
it looks like kuba is gonna actually be
coming up to the stage here we're going
up against it neo but I found our kuba
plays on an octagon and it makes so much
it makes so much time wasn't it yeah
he's such a caveman
laughing he is he go he drags his snake
by the toys yeah he holds it by the
joystick which if you don't know that is
like very bad for ya can't be good for
it and I found out like four buttons on
it are broken Oh
oh boy me over a million don't look him
in the eyes man
so it's like that substitute teacher
that like shows up to your class like
five minutes late with coffee in his
hand and shades and he hands you a
package he's like that is my children
today watching gone in 60 seconds yeah
Akuma is definitely the substitute
teacher that shows up with a packet and
a black coffee like me he's like alright
look get out of my face you tell the
teacher or I'm flying showed up late
I'll kill you she goes and sits down
Jesus come on man shake his hand
mr. chemistry no we're watching God in
success watch she's gone in 60 seconds
have you seen this this is a story of my
life mr. Kubat I'm 15 I don't know about
his no look children watch and suffer
like he's just such a man he definitely
strike out on the wife he's gone in 60
seconds but he definitely strikes me as
a Nicholas Cage guy I could just see him
turning the movie on and then setting up
his switch and playing for nine hit just
screaming in the middle come on
so I think he's got the hamburger me
going on right now what do you have
looks like the arms Oh like what do you
call that the expansion what it's
happening he just opened his stick he's
got rust on his joystick there's rust
what look at his right hand is there
where it is right palm rest there is
rust on his arcade stick what does that
meet how are my hands messed up this guy
gets the live every day of his life
swinging these things around when he's
grinding the top of this thing into
nothingness
my hands are breaking because I tried to
do an ergonomic choice and this guy's
over here is swinging from tree to tree
right there get clipped by it as a big
starter life is so breaking front you're
dead
kudos team outputs 808 their level one I
love the best bump on the game one of
the best buffs in the game it brings you
back down to the ground yeah
allowing for much easier Z changes oh
man just landed and got the jab yeah and
Cooper is one of those players that you
never played them before I don't like
your chances in a two out of three swing
up the tree to tree with the perfect
chances I feel like our so it's very
hard having these gotten gains off some
of the best players in the world instead
three sets right like five o'clock yeah
yeah cool apiece
they are to be legitimately very on
and he's very close to qualifying
actually in terms of points the plays
out yes exactly got third at
thunderstruck on a total point there
we're gonna perform well here it's the
level green what's next all cheerful
overhead is blocked oh and then he
bypasses the third overhead and goes to
the direct rush perfect choice that's
the kill does he have the spinning meter
and the trunks extension and sparking
still available for Kouga complete
control yeah so here knee over a million
this is a pretty rough spot the auto
combo the third hit the scooping of all
set now he's got the outer couple fall
but going to brown bounce that kuba
knows that combo yeah if he gets a hand
you're dead there right so ingredients
pretty rough swap feet yeah most def
especially because the hit has that
unload the cam and super now as well so
he can spark up that a ton of meter and
then just going back he wants to hit it
in a cheeky fashion oh yeah gonna work
against the blue fire my friend yeah
unfortunately
oh you know what's gonna kill ya like it
was like but what if you were to find a
good brush what might that mental damage
for the next day what if instead of
killing my dad and that's how saw we saw
yeah that's the thing
you know Cooper's the type of guy he's
not even on camera and you guys yes he
is occupying enough of the camera oh
that headbutt is repeated sorry I'm
surprised actually that is don't try to
wake up but we don't see this kid be
really a play last time we didn't see
any of it so that was it at the end
sparks up yeah I mean you saw how in
control the hit was from last night by
so cool but not wanting to get rid of
this hit just yet [ __ ] the world and get
caught you had dragon rocks behind the
change the future SS yeah so tough to
deal with blocks under a deceptive on it
on hand for the skies you've done about
Larr that was a great challenge people
have gotten really good at actually
challenging under gg-go kisses you know
as good as it is like you know if it
hits the air and you're chilling on the
ground down there you can challenge
people running up look for the shining
slice is a meaty but that's gonna do it
anyway change the future for the bounce
use that you go through assists like
it's like a straight horizontal beep
sometimes especially like after a smart
situation like that and yeah if you're
crouching and hating buttons you're
gonna suck at every Kong yeah first time
I saw that I think there's go easy and I
was like you know what of course you're
a cheater I look good - good
you just hit - mmm under it like to be
at somebody else's so yeah right that
way this is the death ball for a while
alright let you log down well yes
even though kuba made a block it in the
air I'm gonna respect the additional
blocks on the deal familiar not soul
respectful alcohol yeah against Google
someone's gonna try that stuff
otherwise he'll be super disrespectful
to you
oh you should try goal for the punish
right there but the young spoiling that
Oh surprise you ain't go through the run
over vanish like it's already did
anywhere on the screen yeah I left the
last part rip I mean you'll take that
kill it's better than last game when
prefer now y'all just us quite the
spoiler now I think it's probably really
good against someone like goo Rhodes is
waiting for you to make mistakes we can
react just got that I wanted to see the
molars Oh not gonna kill all the two out
this for the don't GG flash shining
slash and just whip the to jump age and
they strode up a dragon rush Wow
beautiful with butters right that do
brother
not quite three bars but yeah super and
control Kubas chillin or challenge again
and Kubik the dealer silver set to o and
move on in the winner's bracket double
to triple the last ymca i think i think
it was like dad fmcs the point I'm not
sure
oh man we even got a little of the back
and it was a wasn't quite big booty
Jackson it was a minute it was a vision
in the end I missed it beautifully we've
seen a lot of kuva and the last like
we've seen a lot of him that the person
so much so that I think I need to take a
walk so we're gonna take a quick break
here hopefully get away from the visuals
that are haunting are nightmares but
don't you go anywhere cuz we'll be right
back with some more Dragonball fighters
now super noon up to one again this was
one of our round one out winners bracket
top eight matches and applause man was
able to take it now that three out of
five set super new needs one more
victory he already spent his super -
holy taxing apart off forever now but
the actually loses to the jump light get
that out of here the solar normal - good
only caught him spit come press the
button I'm not sure we just eat the
damage or what get away no wiggling out
for super no wiggling out for super noon
talk about adjustments here comes
beneath with the bigger the district of
this set so far the special beam can
three great touches to death
yeah I've been just like that the super
noon bar dog already on the bench
all amanda back - to jump h the tricky
stuff really on point with them now and
yeah super news one of those guys is
gonna keep pressing the issue oh yeah
definitely he has to right now he's that
the life these that live deficit and he
also has the biggest payment the beneath
that no you're not coming back on me
right now we are not going another round
but you know you see down pic bun super
noon is so aggressive right now apology
man starting to take advantage of it
yeah he's just letting that happen you
know like right now apology man just has
to chill he just has to chill because
super noon is moving too fast right now
it brings me with you an apology man now
saying he said my dragon rush oh man
whoa I'm standing wait you can get no
Gengar cancel he's still recovering
though and he jumps out of the command
grab setup super new survives by either
the jump age yes he's gonna pulling back
here now you cannot cancel once more
just can get out of here such a great
block for super noon oh no Spartans are
just gonna take the big damage just
gonna do it go smart and that's exactly
what super new needa to use the slowdown
pick his spot and just let it rip
vanilla style
joining me for a walk drop razzle-dazzle
only he just started the wrong super
dashes super noon always so
disrespectful
Kancil yeah this is advantage old tries
to reflect doesn't get there in time to
punish the will I got to hold that
hardball oh yeah
medium perfect attack that put them in
the corner as well still a huge combo
starter don't get it twisted look how
much damage she's put on display level 3
now you have to imagine apology man
thinking about sparking and so is super
noon oh no he just bought the safe jump
on oh there it is oh he gets out of that
too he did not kitchen because that was
a rocky was too high for him yeah but he
did block the Vantage in the air right
so that's additional Blythe under very
very hard to discern when you're an
advantage or not in situations like that
hold a home zone super - catching the
van issue looking real cool right now
nothing upsetting him right now just
punished
the call-out does not wanna do a yarn
ball tasty hit goes off the Momo apology
man but he was things might need to go
down like that in the dragon rush that
was so smart and sparking a Scottie can
not do the fifty Venice until Hornets
are gonna matter contention on going
down the mall g-man readjust himself in
his seat man now those empty banisters
will no longer be able to bait the two
agents if he does it again he's gonna
eat a big old fist in the button
solar coming on it ha here gets the hard
knockdown
you can have the kid buu assist for the
mix-up as well that's why he guarded the
Crouch mangano homes and things that
curse of the down tech lives on couch
medium distance on beaucoup beige is the
overhead interesting stuff i think he
missed up his instant air - that's why
he got five eight Dunkin on'em
oh but he gets up at the stand like this
is not gonna be enough damage to put him
down but he's gonna be the corn he's not
gonna let him bother you with the mean
ol no burners from the key blasts no
it's only one time ended up at all eh
down goes beneath third place and super
noon NRG grandpa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up everybody welcome back to
first attack here in Puerto Rico
Tenkaichi event the very last one on the
tour stage a man Rindge and we're
enjoying some of these top 32 qualifier
matches that are gonna be hitting hot
and heavy and first up somebody I
haven't seen play yet today Bernie Coors
hot shower hot chicawa in the building
all the way from Japan of course looking
for those points trying to qualify for
the finals of the tour and man every
time I see him his hair is that a new
evolutionary he's got like a real Joker
things going on with his hair like he's
got a he's got a Joe Dirt thing going on
you're not wrong but I was not expecting
the reference joke dirt on commentary
today I can't respect a man but on the
other side yeah that's much more that's
kind of your side right so more 2019
right yeah Joe Dirt is definitely you
know something that's kind of falling
out of favor yeah what is trying to his
hair dude just get a haircut you hippie
that's wrong Pop's cow of course
representing burning for all the way
from Japan as you mentioned trying to
come on here and get some points points
I'm sure we'll see him at the Japan saw
goes well yeah for sure
first come first serve baby no more
lottery do you have so I flew Todd
Chicago we'll see him there hopefully
you see him at the Spain saga as well
cuz again he is one of those that's
after the points right he's not so
secure and the soccer spots are off
falls right so those are great as well
you want to get that auto fall spot if
you can
[Music]
this guy's got a long mustache yeah hey
does like 70% of us man is it extending
I like it goes into the beer it
definitely does it's trespassing not
your territory that's cool man how are
you
it's like they all live on the same
block right yeah so we got a team going
on with Quahog so I'm talking about yet
so check our parking all put in the
freezer on the bench right now we see at
the teen gohan the TT Goku and the
object right
given this current version of the game
you know if you're not if you're playing
Frieza
it's the time but this completely missed
the meeting and then didn't confront me
off yeah if you like the trial of the
second hit walk and switch side
hopefully but either way it's not gonna
be what he's looking for
oh I've got the law tagging the healthy
character this meetings on both sides so
far so you going to get there see you
late
yeah take care make sure you block but
now yeah drag a flatfish into the object
of law and more time and then Lolo
started with the medium to was greedy
about it and it paid off
yeah two n starter on that load that's a
lot of damage to get before the tag as
well so one assist comes up Oh combo
right after the man is no beer he was
swinging with that to L put my friend H
flip back to the front
I I didn't expect them either thought
your collar thought alcohol well we are
whipping the shining slash was trying to
sky this is calling the ground
toxicology the powerful Samman
oh yeah like that so the usual dragon
flatfish they're going to be pretty far
away and the like time you land is a
little funky so he just goes Nagar right
see change smart :
- unfunny hit here the vanish is off
back out of it
all when he caught the key bust a long
time for consider that coverage over the
Roger grant ability
alright thanks to snap actually brings
in Goku black H legs reflects out back -
I think he's looking for a tag name is
but he has actually X down so I don't
know a mr. bascomb Neil blockable tagged
them and the back of the net the old off
blockable it's a quiet bro you gotta cut
the next cut the nape sour oh that's a
big drop and we try to pump a few blasts
with GT Goku not gonna let that happen
and then catch his own as he lands on
the rocket kid
[Music]
for the tumor Center I went down to the
Goku blacks all right gets the convoy is
really hot yeah he didn't know the
standard route because of it you're just
standing out man oh man
level three
Smart's though he bucked off the ground
in Sturgis backed off though yeah he
respected it I think you know not
getting two grades there it's not a
horrible idea
risky super - doesn't get to age Nora
yeah next empathize CallFire closes out
all right but if delayed wake up grown
from a Sarah's able to throw off LED
medium God slicer cotillion
yes going on down the touch the cow was
still with a comfortable lead
no more sparking available for from a
Sarah Raja Colin still has me as lost
two characters that means it's still not
wrong attacks without assists calls
still got garlic answers on so long or
one thing fish in the blood just smacks
into the mouth it's gonna be one old
touch account yeah
change variety it up yeah water drops I
think top Chicago's teen gohan had some
some clear like missus you know like
gets a vanish and then like - up to a
missive some other stuff that is like
clear that maybe you know little bit
been experience on the curve yeah he's
been to go on for a little bit yeah
and Shikoku - you know he's like made
these adjustments to his team it's a far
cry from the team he's been playing for
a long time and then switch
to connect the other gauche rod
eventually memory
Oh points the key blast caches are
trying to escape
there's the stand the air nap right
after
oh I love the way the ancient sound and
look when they're not smashing yeah
they're very very good extension to get
this match anyway hold the whip this has
just been all parts powers upon here
running this offense
Kabam extension in the options vents we
can go hog all the damage hit Hertz this
confident mad damages that he is most
definitely dead even with the weaker
level ones on y'all change Ichiko
[Music]
Jeanne's the future oh you're gonna
climb for the score you're kidding
classes before it's not even looking
like valinor Colwyn out here
how you gonna swing in a sword and be
like well you catch it in between yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like it's right it's
a child swinging at a sword
[Music]
all right put it back into the corner
now already use that smash yeah
I can't believe what we saw six air
money law change the future managed to
age or the other that's often he hit him
with the classic trunks mix-up which is
make your opponent win for a point with
the strongest most potent mix indeed
click the visor to go honest if a DP
property in again town he's pleased and
he's an assist you know that one right
there he's looking for the tag so I
talked to Carl was just walking
backwards from the San so doesn't want
Telegraph that offense is after
double flip on it once again an old
trunk mix-up just make a whimper reflect
I thought you guys you don't people up
punishes to be in since balls over the
point character now he's gonna get a
mound nice and safely
good choice level three here's the trunk
someone capo away from Devin about the
guys preserve its goals with an electron
that's the old Japanese right now the
old and Japanese special care - you talk
to jump out the dancer cause I've missed
the combo we get the light light anyway
a little place with this market for
scholarly commandingly
little heart here's a couple horses die
and now the ox has been over them as
well
yeah he's gonna do proclaim Christ the
dragon Rossi still very healthy cheesy
go through those problems ooh and Sparky
available
Oh air - children that was really fun he
loved to say long distance Olivia extend
those is their names for this party
because in five oh yeah yeah I want to
be proud of move and since then it's
been akela
hey you're gold for my Sarah taking that
function call with y'all sugar this is
cool work take you how long definitely
lower home it's got to get through this
GT that's easier said than done of
course dragon flash backed by the DSS
use here that makes about the word yeah
any a spark available available so he's
gonna spend it you go to Mexican either
apart right
that game you saw one of the hits of the
second couple with yeah that was gonna
drop across the front okay
children moving on oh my goodness girl
yes zoom in zoom in real nice and time
No
and IANA perfect
Sobchak cow man my favorite Japanese
playing right there well though his hair
he's inspired by Western culture clue hi
his fan of those asteroids that fell out
of the earth or fell out of the air mad
without actually alive from the movie
yeah I'm impressed I can't remember any
lies you don't remember anything I've
seen it but I can't remember anything
space rock that he has remember tell the
story on a radio station that's
literally in the end is there like a
Radio Shack no I think it's like a
religious the radio station it's like
yeah he's like recollecting I was gonna
say it's a Radio Shack that's like the
most nineties thing of all time it just
doesn't exist anymore
Oh like the hairstyle yeah on the top 32
qualifier man coming up to the stage
we're gonna have no economy in the
building versus cannon cannon not
Kenneth Bradley no Kenneth's from Puerto
Rico
Kenneth Alberto Riga you know I've
noticed that everybody has a Dragon Ball
sure to Puerto Rico look everywhere I've
walked even if they don't play dragon
ball they've all got dragon ball sure
and when I asked him what earlier what
the most popular game is here Dragon
Ball was like the first they were like a
dragon balls huge hole Wow my dragon
ball is very big oh I see CTR whose
console is this who's trying to race on
the mean streets trying to race on the
mean streets trying to screw around
no that ain't coolest though powerslide
no I don't think so
Callisto Callisto we'll be down the
rental two yard you know yeah you'd have
something he would play Coco for sure
Blanco Coco put the handles I feel like
he's a big body guy personally no that's
me beat up like pine he doesn't play
tiny you got you got B on one side of
the fence I'm tired of you what cause
we'd be like man Rubick by the carry
there's another grappler I don't play
big bodies that I grab place automark
difference yes you know no let's play
travelers that are medium bodies
actually is that you play big bodies if
you play grapplers where you don't play
big body grab
yeah perfectly I played big bodies if
they're media besides and I play sorry I
played I played grapplers up there
medium-sized and big bodies that they're
not crowned play I see I see you know
I'm saying
yeah that's Howard's going to get the
status quo yeah and respected of course
no coffee here looking to get some more
point shot qualified for the finals of
course he did have top mate at evil 2018
right so I mean no economy has shown
that he can be in the top his tier when
it comes to Dragon Ball fighters always
gonna roll up the sleeves show it off
the arms I don't was gonna say I'm gonna
say it's like a jersey like its dad it
hardly has sleeves to roll out but
they're clinging to those biases being
in the gym working out getting his mind
right his body right yeah I feel like
he's twice the size of the last time I
saw oh yeah in person he's like twice
I'm very thin when I last saw him I was
like wow no longer man he's fungus yeah
no commie
they're putting as much time for the
dragon ball at the gym so he is ready
for Puerto Rico on first attack
what was huge
everybody has Super Saiyan God t-shirts
here it's great
everybody's gone with the 5l but don't
call me started with mystic ball GT guns
like the BB bit holy smokes
[Applause]
sage the third overhead and then goes
whoa cockpit the standing up Willie
sparks hey Flint Lo and how do it can
extend and even knock him into the go
curses dragon rise one bar kill Wow you
only still have your cards at all
yeah you look Lauder Peter that whole
sequence he didn't really spend anything
until the very end
yeah I need to go we couldn't quite get
the call home he has vanished with nine
times in the last like five seconds
clicks all around man is man for the
confirm gumball again I empty love and
no copy one every single successful
mix-up no your guys gonna quit by the
pixel ball because of it boy err that's
age connect that's another kill
therefore no commie same comms up last
time
the extensions rather than working okay
Eddie beam oh and the red key change
into the GT go through cuz you know and
GT go can touch the sea with this much
meat in it dad yeah I mean look at how
much Howell kid booth lost you wanna let
him regain some the back and he's lost
so much life oh yeah I guess three is
that anyway let me get let me see the
bowlers ya LaVon the one
perfect there was chimp oh no no no you
can't just laugh like that after
perfecting the man look at the way don't
don't look at the crowd come on man come
over see beach on fire back some ass
knocked out back to the bar as you can
pulling up them right there but man no
hobby for those too many times too young
bit outside and so winging a dragon ride
can DB change into another super yeah
that one's one of the ones you can see
it to you you just do it and if it
doesn't kill they come down the Express
to the corner so that orthopod and level
three get off me
the marginal cava
ronzo gets the comma with the jump-out
afterwards and spent meters so he's got
the meter penalty
there's this one Wow is it a little bit
the chest breaker ketsana - hoi now that
works double overhead mystic ball yeah
got peel off from the light this is
[ __ ] scary
that was messed up I cannot believe that
was with the other side yeah prefer the
front right he appeared their daughter
Leslie get a spark up try to fight me
the meter scale yeah looking like he's
gonna qualify the top 30 winners pretty
comfortably yeah well click law and then
the confirm the lead stream they catch a
nerd
[Music]
no commie internet to do that but you
see it do it again I thought he was
gonna Dragon Russia loses all point
ambiences come on no commie like you
ain't gotta do it like that
wow you shook his hand so nicely - yeah
Keith they like don't pretend he leaned
in and shook it like it was the nice saw
laughing at the camera oh he knows the
folks at home enjoyed the show
I don't know what he said I don't know
what he said either way more lame into
the way you shook his hand he's like
good game so then he walked I was like
no it wasn't it wasn't good games like
you were you think you're so slick you
are but you think you are and that's
what matters right it doesn't matter
that you are matters that you think you
are
so no companies could be moving on
winners bracket top 32 qualifying match
yeah so well done from a bunch of
qualifying matches coming all the
matches next I think gonna be top 32
Falls oh yeah that was a winner sighs so
he's gonna be moving on staying alive
and that upper bracket and then dropping
down to where all the Sharks are the
losers cuz it looks like we are going to
get a ton 32 cause you said again it's
gonna be winners once more lungs
services honey badger yeah
softly badger jury in the first block
pools I could not recall his team but
we'll find out soon
it played very well obviously still it
winners we'll see how long that shall
last yeah I see I mean this is a top 32
quad right so that's a great position to
be on either way risking his life
risking everybody's life this guy Logan
I thought you were professional hit in
the light yeah hit the light you know
how it is I he's still thinking about
our romantic walk on the beach that's
why you guys are weird
I don't understand your guys's
relationship you wrestling fans you guys
are weird
yeah breasts look my best friend if you
like wrestling if you like that kind of
wrestling you're just a little weird at
least aren't you that kind of risk
no I'm the other kind of rusty oh man
you guys miss them Chris my hair that's
a perfect I'm very happy that I missed
it too
I was looking at the monitor lungs
slippers honey badger honey badger
coming up again this is the man you
talked about earlier having similar hair
having to deal with the humidity what
was the discussion happening here I
can't imagine what it is I feel like he
was like playing mind games or I can see
the one that was like yoga I gotta put
his head home again in the middle of the
match
if he starts his man without the
headphone I'm positive he's gonna start
behaving that's definitely a threat a
lung stir X going up against them again
this is a winterside top 22 qualifier
and I got super noon versus Captain
Mason ac-130 on deck that's wild
you be you think you'd be playing bottle
Walker and I'll dodgeball partners you
know he's got the camera I was gonna say
oh really well I mean look oh this guy
know I'm talking about
captain ac-130 over there well captain
ac-130 how many kills that that's a lot
forgot eighty nine nine nine minutes
yeah wow he's got a little bottle right
there what are you say on it not sure I
hope so looks like work in making sure
everything is all good cuz this is the
man who's analog stick didn't work last
time
yeah I feel like he's got a million in
that I've got sleeves got all the
gimmicks yeah he's got like oh I got a
bandana oh my my analog wasn't working
the Sun was in my eyes Oh what oh this
is trashed
oh yes the neck crack as well something
from here it comes the bandanna
[Music]
you better get that bandana on dude hey
hey I thought he was gonna start or I
thought you started too early last time
a button check maybe come on doll the
hand warmers the Chris G special yeah
the hand warms is I only give Chris G
the pass because he plays like 50
thousand games he's gotta remember how
to play the game yeah first like in the
past - hey dude it's a bunch at the
screen yeah so whatever they got to do
you know it's not an air - there's not
that many buttons this is why I don't
call the button press anymore we know
the buddy so warm up the hands all right
look you guys mad enough Frogger Frogger
yeah trying Baker cut you old me and
Logan actually played Frogger on the way
to the freakin beach man cuz we didn't
know which way to go
it always comes back to you and Logan
yeah we had to be popping through the
cars just a 9 inch pipe is well that
part wasn't romantic that was definite I
scared for all I get to see him sweat
then we were running for this posh
British accent these are so upset all
right it looks like we've made it set
and ready
[Music]
long stir this is honey badger I hair
back right this is the star but what
about the band then you know what we
tight as it long Sturgis stands up and
screams just a counter the Vandana this
stanza becomes 6-foot or just screams
into the mic
okay he's putting the headphones on
early looks like he's always and they're
mine he's got take it off the ban on you
better hurry up bro he's running out of
time
oh wait we did the screen keep it's
great boy hey hold on guys he's gonna
hold the time gonna hold the time he's
got a synchronizer oh he did wasn't it
please the first one but still I give it
an 8.5 out of 10 that's pretty still
well done
[Music]
dudes are really fun to something around
perfect attack Tod bar not dad all we
tried to to HR that yesterday that's
good early read from lobster yeah
that's not an easy one either right like
you really call like how that aired a
Spadina Karen back what is this new one
here we gonna hold on to it
Ali's perfect Agron get him out of the
corner instead of chocolate apetito
sneaking five cuz he was swinging on the
ground
yeah perfect time for the sides hood
[Music]
late rolling crush for the knockdown
try to cover the uptick right there the
party this times advantage to exceed the
bar cancel yeah and you try to turn to
punish it on the other side hoping that
it was gonna whip and then you get a
punishment if they just a little t-bar
smash not down here on the corner back
there cover the up check double overhead
block let's get the raw back out now if
it's icky actually calm off that yeah
lots of pressure superdad slew the ki
blasts well the monster already too so
keep it in the air so he just goes with
a direction change level three objects
yeah a level three
[Music]
we'll take the overhead there but good
blocking below in the jump on that
you're a gear up once there is that
means offensive read they play committee
to command off the combo yeah drop to
push I'm not sure yeah that's weird
are this is all about to be back nice
and pick up the avocado instead of
Smashing you choose to vanish yeah I
would've liked see there's master set
again it uses everything right yet so he
could have oh part of makita happy a
nice and sparks out
we have columns with abject I'll hold
the banner brother follow-up
[Music]
might've get it all back here
yeah I drank run back to the corner of
the sands that look like a fake right
yeah look like command role is gonna be
the option to make you wiggle they
cancel it for the be more abilities
[Music]
yeah burn through some of this life give
it to the sparking be peace available
though when I look like that's we goes
looking forward staggered to push the
first pot but catches in the second pot
[Music]
so long stare down a sparking down
character early try to drag across
finally gonna land on the beam and then
have blocks fun to set that up goes back
to the original side doesn't get clipped
by the emperor 21 but I'll follow up
yeah I like the tag I think honey
badgers doing jump out ll above it was
like I don't really know what to do a
cell here pretty tall yeah let's get
that man out of here for a second
we are staggering those lights each
teleport to the other side he has to
believe in that one right here I go jump
medium is just 2h directly but he does
give it to wait on the raw attack that's
a great look built the four bars closely
to the level one level three solar
kamehameha yes the kill
two characters apiece
honey bachelor fours with a happy heater
advantage here force of nothing
[Music]
oh the confirm
fives man
keeps expanding it aside from that
problem to call this the corner level-3
afterwards you're gonna kill but with no
sparking no guard cancel meter
availability real cousins what you got
just goes with the late over here to be
it mixes in he adds just put by the end
of it
so logo the black not an easy spot to be
in
wow it doesn't even cancel anything out
though th she's back - eyes get started
never sir look sir it got a little bit
work to go then give one couple these
one more barn off yes there were tons of
- oh but you said uh-huh and then that
dump will jump out of the corner from
honeybadger
good music you are canceled so low pays
off that's on and that's over the point
of the confirm that was great stuff the
2h little bit scrambling finish that
combo a little late great maybe a
javelin throw - art still white looking
at me it's the other me real good uses
of it as he was trying to up back Roger
is expecting that
wow he tried the 2h that but those sir
no sir
that was actually a good try yeah was
too late
I feel like that's one of the moves that
got changed I can't remember who has
change to like be harder to to ancient
order for it to be easier that's a good
question I there's a lot of moves in
this game that have been yeah they've
like change the property is my man
adjusted the bandana will see the other
guy look the intros watch a second time
I feel like this is unprecedented
yeah fair enough fair enough fair he
can't put the yeah he's pertaining to
put on again Wow alright I like it he's
like I am part off put on a couple you
in real life
laughter you have to support in effigy
this is gonna jump back yeah that's
really like the wall in this match a
Breitling and tell páginas this is gone
you do have to be careful about
approaching you see the whip on the head
first into the auto combos with a second
to bring it back to the ground you know
what's funny is that every time he does
this combo it always wish like that so
that means he's okay with it you know
Sophia bees are actually pretty good for
keeping characters together generally
especially when he's perfect attack to
AIDS and that miss Nesbit he called the
D doses preemptively as well as we have
nothing to expend was with again could
have been rolling cross vegeta vanish
beat the van and help and it's in the
back - oh why she's gonna kill that guy
because he was expecting him to manage a
very smart
oh yeah just brought aegisub Machida you
spell the kill especially without
meeting yes they're just going with a
rapid ki blast station that's perfect
right like that's what you want you want
to get the kill there without spending
any bar and if it's off tide will take
it off to L class
we can sit around one small snack
wholesomer fire one character at a time
get the command grab they're all level
three nothing too crazy some damage off
that well I thought you had the
chocolates for you
oh yeah that's the signature type of oh
yeah
age teleport back to the front yeah the
cool things about Silas is where I since
it moves you we have teleporting moves
like Bhagya the back of a funny little
behind ya drag across before the assist
connects shows of the Vegeta GAO's
thinking about the real threat from the
blobs to get the track
it's 1/3
Big Bang bring itself for the kill
got a slicker clean game here for long
stir especially the spark install at the
table you know if you get a hit here
that's seventy percent and of course the
true so player make sure the done at
that time
yeah a little works yeah some players on
that perfect acts have to do all to be
these two ages have been really on point
vanish and slides there back to the
corner and the first thing we saw Pro
clunks the rises to H attempt call out
in the in America for us to begin to
that was a great confirm actually to see
that that it hit
hilltop Walker as well
three will be closed yeah take as much
as you can get yeah I know
Ronna DP a third intro this is on
profits actually ridiculous is he gonna
put on the bandana a third time
No ah he's betrayed his roots I mean you
didn't lose the last game to be fair
toss which now both of them look so
serious
and here at night even tried to reflect
after block with ejido system good thing
they get hit by the honey badger that's
what looks a little auto reflects life
so got to ever way to close the distance
all right then the kid shows up the
pudgy doesn't drag the Russian before
get out yeah that sister extent here for
the kill
that's awesome there's a bear early kill
on a very important character for this
see what happy words you are it's about
that damage himself is what you get into
the shadow brain it's like a capture
stay like sanic that doesn't allow that
damage to come through anymore man I
can't believe that part oh it's not bad
I could never come back to buy it up
especially the honey badger giving the
Hedgehog bandage confirm - back is an
assist as well now so you have to be
careful you're on the ground up against
honey badger any staggers h Talib roar
no reflects the commander oh yeah love
that micro - into the a dragon rush wolf
yeah that was an interesting idea to be
I think well like make up his double
side switch or something right I was
like the idea yeah so was gonna push you
back to one side and like the original
second got a block on was gonna decide
you need it to block on but did not come
together how he wanted a triage Apple it
does finish the carrot man he should
meet dead haha man he should be extra
there but he's alive and now he's out
not down at the corner here
I step down for supper by the one
character again we're gonna spark up on
that character so I'll try and chase it
with the help bandage but still can't
make a block their doubts over try to to
age it there's the cancel
[Music]
the extensions now time to come back
down the jump back it kind of look like
he was respecting uppercut and then it
turned out looking dog to commit to my
facebook snap a gap all to H the heck
can't challenge once of to eight I'll
play his own game against the south
north that barn on key all alone
give it back ups people ages of the
people at the town
he's been resting his whole time and to
kill without spending any extra bar
that's a good look
so two characters the piece perfect good
night around perfect a thing built
another sparking for some really comes
out and gives it to you know what for
being so committed he's got a bar like I
said stable and I bar not gonna steam
this veteran comes up with the holy
symbol divine intervention eros below
look lovely level that are gonna not
found what you got oh trying to hit a
button and you're dead honey badgers try
to sleep that's who L in there long
starting ago ended up getting the jump
out himself
any badges took the headset on becoming
one with the game snipe nice punish
follow us at the bet smashing our town
with a roll across here Oh - Peck - a
from honey badger at all
it's the type of game you want to play
we can get in the bus
[Music]
they're kind of move forward a little
bit they ready for a guard camp gotta go
yeah I thought he was gonna block in car
canceled we got one character apiece now
final game between needs to the qualify
for top 32 on the winter side an air
stop the honey badger here before we go
contingent game loud level three you're
out of the corner but you're one mix-up
away from dying will once the DP oh it
looked like you try to bait it top 32
winners bandana comes off well Bordeaux
Rico proud that their boy made it in the
top 32 winners side he's like that was
good yeah he's like man yeah I messed it
up but like such a wholesome comment
from Lux I even know what he said play
some sense are you trying to play so I
was just thinking we should play some
sense real cool to see real cool to see
the ox out he's been great in Puerto
Rico in general I everybody's been super
friendly yeah super attire oh you know
what so we have to top 32 matches coming
up we have super new vs. Captain vanes
in a c-130 they all duty referee the
match after we have are ours fidelity
versus ray-ray yeah the reason that's
interesting to me is that I was told
that fidelity is probably the number one
dragon ball player here Oh most people
said that that's like the strongest
dragon ball players I was told earlier
that was by somebody so maybe they were
lying and fidelity to their best friend
but I was told that fidelity is beasts
so I'll see yes I find out that after
this match of course super noon and
captain mace and a c-130 captain mace
and a c-130 the legend what a nation
what are the numbers mean I hope we have
like a laptop to the sides I'm not even
playing casual something to it up yeah
excuse me death match
it's playing honey vermin what called
you that was Jesus lighting it rock the
8130 you know I asked super nude about
this shirt and he said a friend bought
it for him okay just because they
thought it would fit him right yeah
about the shoes hey I was like you're
not even wearing these like air forces
always yeah and he was like oh I don't
even own him and I was like what was
that picture of them in a hand he's like
oh I google image grab that and I was
like why did you tweet that he's like oh
because I'm gonna buy a pair for go Ichi
yeah he was like he said something like
if go each he wins this tournament I'm
gonna buy him a pair of Air Force Ones
okay black Air Force Ones and give them
to him I don't know yeah I don't know
but he doesn't have the shoes like that
was a Google image just like he doesn't
even have them to give to go eat yet
know what uh come on man but he's buying
go eat see a pair of black air for the
sky tops that's what the sky pop or
super high top Air Force Ones for go
Ichi I just know every time he tweets
that picture he always tweets the
symbiont Spidey in the rain app I don't
know why every time what is it though
are you being like taken over by another
feed so that your spider powers don't
work people say that all the time a big
mood I'm like you're not spider-man what
evil being is taking control of you from
another planet oh man what alien
entities sort of Secret Wars like the
comic series like what like what are you
talking about
so we'll see it was super new channels
this alien entity that's corrupting to
be yeah whatever our captain may see
ac-130 gets that uh is that kill streak
going
so I wanna see the kill kill streak
incoming locked and load on the headset
better find some cover
yeah you got a piccolo Bardot Goku the
eSports scene man did not lose that the
character select screen that is for sure
yeah not yet seen her before socket the
signature stuff on his sidekick blue bar
not Goku GT you know the good times are
rolling I can't wait to see how much
work is his bar log puts it yeah on the
other side we got our team hook gang gob
representative here in Captain Mason
because the hook gang God has retired to
the stream he's a streamer like me I'm
here leaves the cave but may I'm gonna
go pick new CTU goes down the street
with the size fellas busy streaming
cabinet I was like I'm gonna tuck my
shirt in his honor I opened up early but
standard kid boots no fight mystic bar
put the bar back this is behind you lock
you down and then guess how many
overheads will come your way
saw the reflect bad I can't believe it
to a horse on the other side yeah like
it doesn't surprise me if it's like you
know a car cancel in front
look at that tentacle around someplace I
gotta pay action flat lock twist
oh I thought it'd go to h3 already
committed to keep watch the combo off
the two acts and Supergirl not a scratch
on them so falling on the barn on Ole
Miss things to go and what's funny is
that suck out the base of the land and
do it - oh yeah baby yeah hit the two
out here yeah it's late you already saw
all border
Oh spark but he was actually still
blocks on full reflects took some chip
but snatches them yes indeed
so snow perfect yeah the hook perfect
they need a bar dog
Stumpy's out of that she's got a couple
of hot today arrived where they go to
cancer TV a jump a 356 a little bit too
early on but press yeah have mystic ball
air - back he blasts super new tried
there may be two eight try stopping
falconhawk this is Beth rehab
the treasure to give a guy hit clipped
by the key but they want like everything
want hey definitely does all I just take
it to the bud stomps amount into the
Sparkie I let the log this jump em
cockles again a long way along you know
it's funny cat that Mason was like
that's my bad front of that anyway what
he told him he was like my bad but I'm
not stoked there yeah man was trying to
close the application he was doing one
of those we were just like mashing the
button to get through in the mash and
during the super art not even to her the
silver before he wasn't even dead but
then he was dead Mike uh bacharach's leg
spring he go see Superman I'm seeing a
queue up the same ol team
same ol order when it's good what he's
in this bad what's he holding on to
though that is the UH the candy that
don't you once used you know he's got
copied all going shoes but he's like
behind yeah like a year old be an apple
trend I don't see any speed reading
where's the speed reader yeah he's got
the eye drop he's like two months got to
keep up with the times and then like a
year from now he'll have he's like the
Europeans and the be me it was popular
like years ago and now they're like we
kid boo-boo I shall live but there's a
basket blue where's my favor one okay
guys on the screen every time the way
you said that gets me every time it's
like why it's always on the screen yeah
off the screen what the guys it's like
the same damn food truck
oh that's [ __ ] 6/10 to start oh man
i'ma start them out again
[Music]
sometimes you gotta poke pretty cool toe
it's got the shoulder blades
Wow this jump mallets doing work
rocketbox is off my shoulder blades
yeah smash up on the feeders do it
sleeper damage he represent set up shop
again dragon she's that is the age gonna
kill coordinates Dunbar these are [ __ ]
says
the spirit spirit realm and I told you
his ball office is perfect
these were [ __ ] he decided
it's Bartok you know yippee Thank You
Chuck sparking me my back and off
let's want to stop about consistency for
reset the sparked lot to keep that
dragon rush in the corner but this time
Beatrice Hall five super close I guess
he knew you know help then in class that
was the crazy part I didn't expect that
vanish out
the cap on the sense
knock him into the gg-go Chris's guard
can such Ramanujan got the quick level
one spare ball cliff by the raw tag from
super duty trucks Thank You frontal area
yeah
we know about his boner
all fakes the cause of the fall for for
the long jump L gets the job done
super names legendary fought off on
point our captain Mason oh that does
housing on landing recovery friends but
not that many
look you a couple left one to level
three wait has he lost the character yet
elevator business Bartok any video you
want to read that Bartok back in yeah I
mean that's what he wanted so he could
get the snap I mean it's still a long
way to go here we go he's gonna have
black available gonna walk up in 6 mm
this is that out so really late overhead
attack some riders who level 3 super
news takes it to oh it may be qualified
in a winner side conference over captain
Mason ac-130 that's alright gives him
more time the queue for team deathmatch
that's true trying to get the kill
streak yeah I don't know what both best
we can to kill States maybe domination
headquarters yeah you play a team
objective mode and you just
yeah but uh looks like that match has
been completed obviously and we're gonna
be moving on some more time thirty-two
qualifying match it's gonna be fidelity
as you mentioned before perhaps the
strongest player here that's what I've
heard
until yeah that was told from one of the
commentators earlier that this is what's
called sinners yeah what happens play
one that best player sorry for all my
gosh yeah do W sit up the commentator
told me that this is one of their better
players yeah so fidelity apparently is
very good also we're gonna see him up
against Ray Ray again if you are
familiar with Ray Ray has had great
success throughout fighting game history
right he had yeah top eight balls were
three get rad final this Marvel three
also very good at Marvel incidentally is
here going up against the man or on
tomorrow hat so let's see they got
similar backgrounds I thought those were
big plugs but I think those are
headphones yes I believe so
I was like man that is a crazy plug
that's like the biggest plug I've ever
seen what would a strat that would be
not only do I not want game sound I want
nose yeah at all
rayray of course rock in the zoo Basu up
front right these things a bit
unorthodox got some awesome in the front
again to the back to you I still like
still very strong we just don't see them
a lot yeah I think there's just better
options right without good go go is and
how similar of a job they kind of
accomplish the difference is like you
would think right that like the job for
team would be to shotgun damage but Goku
hurts to yes so it's not like he's like
okay well if I pick TN I get like way
higher damage out of it and like the
Asit like it's like not that different
and like when you have to do triple
level wanna kill it does like hurt the
fact that TM loses some life right yeah
so good that is definitely something
that counts against your character
whether you know it's a little bit of
life but it goes a long way exactly so
both players getting set up ready to
continue this winners qualifying match I
believe this might be one of our last
top 32 qualifiers here yeah this is our
last getting into the nitty-gritty next
out of this I think will be the top 32
yeah since our last qualifier we're
gonna have thanks everybody for sticking
around and watching some good matches
coming up so top 30 to 16 will be out to
this then tomorrow at noon we'll have 16
to 8 and then top eight it's gonna be
tomorrow at 6 or 8 I don't know which
variety make sure to tune in though
we'll all be right here on twitch.tv
slash dragon ball fighters yeah so don't
you worry your head that's where you
this is where you'll find all the action
all weekend long so you don't need to go
anywhere else
just follow this channel
the jackets coming off for only Jizo
cous Frieza hanker Frieza Rollie GT Goku
console staples of the better right now
very good characters yeah the reason
that the heck I was talking about
earlier brawly's weird right because
although he's like a big character with
armor and everything his zoning is one
of his biggest merits right just
incredible iSpring control right because
of the key blacks because of its own
strengths but it's long fiddle moment
yeah and the super armor yeah are more
to means that like - thinking on in this
kind of reckless right with other zoning
characters don't have those kind of
threats mr. Wong look or a one overhead
rail a really watch that mix-up actually
speaking for the double overhead and
going around saw that in the last that
you played as well man Ben yeah number
one just like that it's 40 seconds yeah
the TG Gogu tag was like on purpose you
know one of those like early tanks well
you don't know if it was an accident or
not wall poster there so for a really
long time was fighting for W the war has
strikes this blue strange round start to
write both - up block nothing level
three for the knockdown
laughs after a super - and did not need
a lab after a super daddy I mean I can
move like this
everybody's got in the admit you're not
the only one
the biggest well yeah yeah
banished for the combo no kill here so
all beautiful fidelity even choosing to
skip the Sparky to get the kill now
aside okay
you know fidelity with that one oh man
but barely
immediately turn around look to the
crowd but which one of you which one of
you have y'all shouldn't these things
y'all should do you see these things in
controllers do you think the controller
these secret your choice right now and
it was during a moment where nobody
could do anything right yes boxes around
stuff oh thank you
somebody okay he's got some rookies man
do you think the controller is for cut
32 PSA if you don't want this to happen
during your mash desync the controller
switch right back into the corner we got
some real freaky stuff because there's
Larkin to send me home go to Dragon Ross
a little fighting to space it out so
it's sparking wouldn't affect it but
actually in that case order with anyway
the flat double reflect even reflected
the dish on the way back to Madrid
olives are they
Wow oh no we could go blue - if she
changed out right there that looks low
jump sobral ESS is the monsters bad
right how severe it could be looking for
a raw egg the latest holographic hi
sergeant the fries of jet pile and
punches it yeah and this funny thing of
the crowd as soon as that hit landed
just get so like quiet right like
they're obviously change their fidelity
here I'm gonna get to a life I mean 10
you know at this point let him move life
yeah I mean it's gonna die in one hit
either way here he goes slow fall who's
the boss - this is we saw it start
around with that earlier - yeah I like
that idea
right because you like play often you
know that they're gonna think okay well
if I'm gonna run the tag so just go and
play small fence double overhead car
cancel out Ray Ray oh snap in the TN get
away
using those key blasts super die
so close to getting snare the 2h even
match here I would say really is very
confident of the keeper I think so
partnership they tried to beat it to the
punch with the super - yeah read the key
box coming out
guru scary super - could it doesn't jump
standing out jump into it but hard to
tell that he was in the air in the first
day
and definitely not something easy to
recognize the mole level 3 is purple
City Burger King more time rayray 1 only
yeah I think fidelity has been really
reaching with the airflows right like
either he's really feeding like to get
that one good snatch and then try to get
something out of it the problem is like
I think when that you're committing to
that a lot it's easy for area to play
around it yes very very good at playing
around holdin to like you take the
massage as well I used to it early head
block distance on that 5l to them
oscillate with a clip on my hair - miss
the button on the ball of them
yeah reflect now
[Music]
good ahead air - yes very very you
didn't have any extra cents or anything
so I like that toy so longer actually
that's the raw Tiger a ring
[Applause]
back out runs under dragon or us all
right so doesn't have a negative penalty
from the meter anymore and a sprawling
assist available ice needed the wrong
extension kids in it's gonna be a 1 Park
Hill
first blood to fidelity here really we
saw rare is kid buu do a lot of work
last time very early
we haven't seen too much of the candy
beam at the stars some are clawed 805 is
cursing the sky
here so you get it from the jump age
mystic ball no assist to extend tents
and now double reflect
nice instead of using any bar or
banishing or something like that I like
that extension kisses
[Music]
bringing Ichigo do not always look for
all
fidelity no we have the likely right I'm
gonna get you froggy he's got a strong
zone his hair is there Bowl he got some
good assists the back of all
- more soup with the delayed request for
a range great defense
yeah just wait it out nice and patient
spend some bar here one three lot of
damage
trying to fake video right into the low
gets under the keel and I was so sick
using the slide off the end the dug
beneath the key blasts sparks up as well
it's gonna be enough damage here oh yes
it's the blast so sparking you're gonna
run out here for fidelity cuz really big
sums ray-bans little juice parking for a
little while now and ashes under it
because he knew the momentum of the
staircase is gonna take them over Wow
clash clash with the pure horizontal
food I guess I don't make the rules why
we go the auto propyl actually gets the
raw back and it's the kill most
definitely
[Music]
show them the molars dragon rush Oh
but the 6m anyway Old Faithful hey red
outfit this pretty yet talked about his
damage output of course but yet no
Sparky to mitigate some of that life
loss even wage command grabbing to get a
little bit damaged it's a long road
though especially when you don't get the
2h there yeah the wrong tag you would a
2h that we've been a much better driver
position reflects but not reflect with
the whole spring with this boom again
for the setup their chairs jhump28 to
hang in the air pool yeah even doctor
two ages successfully breeding fidelity
right they're losing a lot of life
that's the unfortunate thing right like
an attack that'll do it one apiece with
the crowd cheering on fidelity as he
ties it up well dump over there he
pounces been only losing one character
that time he's gonna go to game three to
see who gets into top 32
yeah what's that early star very
respected the armor success slugging it
there oh it's hit by the five now put
them in the chest reflect tag is out of
there get the corn I think some baby's
not breathing
quality picks up those Buffalo
successfully a man rare it goes low a
lot on these mixer every day just feels
like you know people are looking out
over at option knee drop connects no
problem there's a monster and there's
great way to dogs all this drug Fidel
you click on screen yeah we've seen a
lot of that low slide from 10 so far
from reveille he's really been favoring
that quite a bit
reflects the pressure after
we can the dragon rushed over here eight
people hold it up until that point here
build that bar you have to take the
trouble they're all beautiful track run
beats out to reflect the tap yeah he was
this committed to it in that case right
like you know fidelity happen to be
admitting to a dragon rush
[Music]
all three they sorta each
don't make he is now here in that
position riot like war fidelity is if
you get a hint you spar this game is
gonna be very tough Pereira to win
I like that he's doing drag for us like
if it worked twice in a row three times
our own just keep committing you know
this coming back reflects some on the
other side it already very we're talking
about it experience against I will call
it earlier
place please the players on the regular
yeah my freeze experience right while
the rock Sudoku P but this big ball
that's very surprising I cannot believe
that honestly yeah I'll go somewhere
right here yeah hope the van is she's
got a chase now that's the problem
reflects put it blocks time this is not
where you want to spend your sparking
used to age all right it's a hint in
sparking this big you know this it's
running out now so you want to try to
get as much damage as possible
not a super effective sparking but a
buildable on a meter and they got him a
lot of damage
yeah put them in a spot to kill this
freak off all good guard cancer live
everywhere here the key blast em
[Music]
the belly do a good job of stretching
the mystic ball popping around and now
he's locked out and does not make the
dragon run
yeah very big the start of some kind of
offense one three
sparking here going low and going to
lower again after making your Blanca
lightning
yeah it's tension to the kibbutz oh
that's not easy I feel like that's one
of the most finicky assistant mom walk
for sure
level one would do it straight stuff
yeah I didn't go fidelity was just a
little bit pick it up back by how long
it was a block sign I think he didn't
expect to like hook up through at the
end snaps out of the air cobble with the
keep live from the vanish go to her huge
yeah that was a long a long time he
explained across the screen staggered I
can't even look at the confessed with a
button of his old locking it out there
it is bring them all the way back down
oh that's so good it was so smart he put
him in blocks ton drop them all the way
down ran up and snatched him on the
first Mantle's we've seen - that's so
cool that situation where you can take
it your video I know how double jump our
hair - alright but you really put up my
block stuff with the freeze over while
I'm trying to wake up a Silurian Express
[Applause]
[Music]
that shop leads to judgment yes marking
out I like that choice fly level 3 on
reacts and of course that's all you're
looking for when you're flying so yeah
its market is gonna recover all that
pool I can come in and this should
probably be close level three
that he built it right at the end
fidelity and top 32 in her side for
Puerto Rico taking it to the crowd going
nuts they must love him here yeah
bouncing back after the first game very
well done from fidelity looking forward
to seeing him take on the rest of the
competition in top 32 yeah top 32 case
you guys are wondering when that's gonna
be when you have to set your clock for
it's right now top 32 is starting right
now on twitch.tv slash Dragonball
Fighters so we're gonna take a quick
break to gather up all the players get
everything ready then we'll jump into
top 32 of Dragonball fighters here at
the Tenkaichi event in Puerto Rico see
you guys very soon